though Cruz is an experienced pilot
himself Jerry Bruckheimer admitted that
the Navy denied Cruz's request to Pilot
the F-18 Super Hornet jet that Maverick
flies in the film despite this Cruz took
it upon himself to Pilot every other
aircraft he could rockheimer told Empire
the Navy wouldn't let him fly an F-18
but he flies a P-51 in the movie and he
flies helicopters he can do just about
anything in an airplane in order to get
around the fact that Crews couldn't
pilot the F-18 himself producers
engineered some pretty ingenious camera
setups Cruz was adamant that the film
not rely on CGI so instead IMAX cameras
were actually installed inside f-18s
while Navy Pilots did the actual flying